[Musique]
l'organisation de ces jeux à paris a
créé une attente et un espoir des
territoires se sont organisés pour
accueillir des épreuves je pense à nos
compatriotes polynésie française pour le
surf et à marseille pour la voile sur
les rives de la méditerranée
certaines collectivités veulent pouvoir
accueillir des délégations étrangères
afin de devenir en quelque sorte leur
camp de base les demandes sont
nombreuses
et nous voulons savoir comment ces
différents projets vont devenir
concrètement des réalités nous avions
besoin de faire un point en janvier 2009
22 sur l'état de préparation des jo à la
fois sur la dimension du sport de haut
niveau est ce que les différents acteurs
qui concourent à préparer nos athlètes
sont prêts est ce que l'organisation qui
peut paraître un peu complexe de
préparation au tour des athlètes et est
bien stabilisé c'était le premier point
le deuxième point c'était de voir si
cette dynamique djo s'infuser biens sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
on a lancé ce label terre de judée 1024
ici au sénat en 2019 on a bien
conscience que
les français dans tous les territoires
doivent pouvoir être associé à la magie
des jeux on va voir le parcours de la
flamme on va voir les centres de
préparation des jeux aussi un peu
partout en france où les délégations
internationales vont pouvoir venir se
préparer en amont des compétitions donc
c'est vrai que
la coopération avec le sénat nous nous
aide vraiment à associer justement
l'ensemble de ces territoires
on a une fenêtre de tir assez unique
avec l'organisation du plus grand
événement sportif de la planète on a
envie de lutter contre la sédentarité
des français de proposer des moments de
sport à tous les étages donc la
collaboration aujourd'hui avec tous les
territoires et assez propice à à de bons
résultats
la réussite des jo que tout le monde
veut c'est bien sûr une réussite
sportive avec des médailles pour les
sportifs français mais c'est pas que ça
c'est aussi une acceptation une
appropriation par les français de cet
événement et pour ça il faut qu'ils
soient irréprochables sur différents
aspects vous parler de l'aspect
financier effectivement ce sont des
événements qui coûte cher il des
engagements qui ont été pris sur un
montant de dépenses et il faut que ce
soit respectée c'est un des aspects
importants il ya l'aspect
environnemental aussi qui est une autre
dimension extrêmement délicat et des
engagements qui ont été pris doivent
être tenues et surtout derrière les jo
il faut que la france se montre
exemplaire aux yeux du monde tony
estanguet rappeler que ne serait-ce que
la cérémonie d'ouverture c'est un
milliard de personnes qui vont avoir les
yeux braqués sur la france il ya peu
d'occasions d'un autre temps d'avoir une
telle exposition de notre pays donc
vraiment il faut que sur l'ensemble des
dimensions nous soyons parfait